great she again Frank yeah absolutely
great what show is this Dan Patrick show
inside inside jokes ah I was thinking
about this when you were coming in of
all the people you do impersonations of
and I'm thinking I've never heard you do
Vin Scully and I would think Vin Scully
with that delivery would be easy be but
you don't do a Vince I don't really do
and you could probably do a better one
than me I mean Harry Shearer yeah I've
heard Harry Shearer do it and it's very
good and all I would ever do is each a
long flyball deep into Shanta field I
mean that's that's all I can I can't say
any other words so it's deep it's decent
enough that you know who I'm doing
although it's not great but baseball is
very regional right other events collies
bigger than that Harry Caray was bigger
than that but to work on somebody even
like a Vin Scully for me you go to
Milwaukee Chicago they don't care so you
throw it out there and it doesn't matter
they don't know you know again everybody
knows Harry Karen I think part of people
knowing Harry Caray is even Will Ferrell
doing on Saturday Night Live and he was
kind of wilful hey it wasn't only
counted just see the guy I mean it
wasn't dead on Harry Caray
it was a great funny will hurt Will
Ferrell bit you know so yeah baseball
baseball that's a baseball that was Al
Michaels doing a baseball it's
unbelievable I saw all the book in the
background damn that's one of the best
I've ever written do you believe in
miracles yes um so yeah base base
baseball I know basically you're Vin
Scully not good no yeah and I admit I
see that's the thing is I hear a lot but
is it is it that he's not something
somebody you can put into your
performance I think or is he hard to
capture I don't know I don't know cuz a
lot of people I don't like it's like
singers I never worked on singers
because the only thing you could really
do with a singing voice is rhyme it at
the end of every reverse that's what the
joke was going to be you know so I went
a different I like to cap
what the person is and what you know
with Madden you get that the look on
your face sir I get the look on my face
like when if he's like he's just ate an
entire lemon you know you're just kinda
starts to feel Gruden's like he's
looking through you man I see you Dan I
know what you're thinking I was working
with tarik on the argument yeah it's a
tremendous job yeah he could do like 50
sports in one day man yeah it's up goody
he walked in one time grew the groom
walked in the Monday Night Football
pre-production meeting I got to go to it
and grood he just rips I mean in a funny
way he's the guy who holds court so
anybody who's never been around he's the
funny guy but it's like everybody's also
scared of him at the same time so I was
like hey 3ko nice of you to join us man
did you finish calling a golf match
doing a couple NBA Finals games then
decide to show up for Monday Night
Football good for you Mike game money
onion is he in on the joke yes I think
he is I think now he's in on the joker's
he been on in on the joke the whole time
from what I think he just does I mean I
think it's just him I think it's him to
start with but you know like when I met
him first cuz Bradshaw was not always in
on the joke yeah Bradshaw thought of
stuff is it's wrestling I mean that's
the way they got them through with
Kimmel it's professional wrestling
that's what they'd always tell them
because especially the athletes and
former athletes they're used to being on
a pedestal their entire lives right
there up there and when you cook you can
make fun of other athletes if you're the
same level as that person if you've
played the game you're in the locker
room you can mess with each other you're
me five foot six this chubby kid coming
in Giroux Bukh isn't like call myself a
little lesson should Rubik lately ah you
come in and you're who's this guy you
just guy doesn't have a you know a right
to make fun of me
so but when you you know Kimmel was very
and people don't even remember that
Jimmy did this um but he was the
original NFL on Fox guy and he would
take those guys apart and rip them to
shreds and then I came in it was sillier
you know and doing the characters doing
it but tears like it's like wrestling
rat like huh I'm mr. wonderful Paul
Orndorff
in here and yeah you want those bad guy
wrestlers
bad guy wrestler yeah I can pretend you
up you know so that was to me you know
they start to get that you know for the
longest time I don't think Madden got it
and I told you the story about me
meeting Madden is like I got it now when
you're with the person it makes sense
and Gruden when I met Gruden he's like
my kids love you man
like how about you my kids love you man
yeah it's but who doesn't get it
or doesn't care to get it but it doesn't
stop you from still know I think
everybody starts to turn cuz people
think it's going to hurt their business
they think it's going to hurt what they
do
cuz Steven Naismith just want you to
talk about him uh yeah absolutely give
me the resolution I didn't think so you
know I understand where you're coming
from that Mister Caliendo and make it
perfectly clear clear that you're
utterly and completely quadrilateral II
deficient in ever category and I have no
idea why I'm so angry today yeah it's
the guys like that is quadrilateral in
the word it is in MAGIX ok cup wad rely
on my hair do that I'm like modulate how
do you argue with the trigonometric Lee
speaking
you got to take the sine of the cosine
and understand what's going on here is
utter in complete symmetry think about
that mr. Kali and every time he talks I
feel like I'm failing in a safety test
what I only got 400 on that I said how
can that be
so but Chris Berman came around to it
yeah yeah I mean you know a lot of guys
you know get big it just seemed did it
and it I mean it
hey it's just Morse code that's my put
on stays on my head stays maybe bad bad
bad maybe babe that was SOS Big Mac
turns into jazz Scott if it gets really
good midday give it back we'll be back
after this but Berman without words is
better I like it because it's the
character part of people to me Madden
got to be more fun when I wasn't even
doing Madden anymore I was just doing
when you have the the moments in between
that's what makes the character and for
Berman it's a you know what date and
I've talked to me it's like you know you
just you just keep talking veg the way
if you keep talking you get you define
you
fine did the words did you an you Jenny
weekly we know where you big baby
how important are the mannerisms the
expressions because a lot of times I
don't do the impression dead-on right
but but if I just heard your voice so
somebody on radio listening now if
you're not doing the facial of Jon
Gruden the Gruden I think you you know
who it is
Gruden's one of those guys but even now
you're doing the face look better it's
better mo here's what you want me to
face that face man
cuz the Chucky face but you got Chucky
you get the eyebrows yeah
it's tremendous man yeah yeah people
laughing all over they're not even in
the studio they're not he's but that's
what makes it fun to me that it is the
encompassing like the whole person
because that's what it's about like
people as you how what cartoon
characters you do I'm like I don't
really do any because you don't see you
know a cartoon character doesn't have
like a real person's mannerisms I like
to find those little things that the
person does a cartoon character it's
drawn to have mannerisms right you you
you you animate to make that happen a
human being doesn't do that stuff on
purpose what about Trump
he's got certain letters pretty it's
tremendous it really is when you think
about and right now I want to say this
and Todd fritzy I want you to understand
wherever you are back there I see you
you're not that thin now let me say this
this is going to be the number one rated
show Dan has ever done and it's going to
get even better
the longer that I'm on the more your
audience is going to grow and it's good
by the end of this you're going to have
tremendous ratings you really are
have you done that for Trump yeah I did
a sketch with him at Fox years ago it
was a what it's there's some great
stories with her cuz he's I don't know
he's like now well let me take a break
okay come back and you can give me your
behind-the-scenes with the tremendous
taken that's a great piece because it's
only going to get better and I want to
know what you're like at Thanksgiving or
something you know yeah cuz I get the
feeling I'm nothing you're not very
excited
yeah I'm terrible yeah so we'll continue
with frank khaled endo what are
comedians like at Holiday time I'm never
I mean I think I don't know what I can't
speak for every comedian because most of
the time I won't spend any time around
yes it's like I've heard there was a
joke a radio guy did who said a lunch
with a single one comedians funny a
lunch with two or three comedians it
gets exponentially worse because they
all start trying to one-up each other
that's like old school kind of comics I
mean I don't know I doubt louis c.k who
I considered to be one of those amazing
guys who can just talk and be funny I
doubt he's trying to to be funny there
he's just trying to be himself and
probably thinking and processing he
might say some funny things
sarcastically but I I and I don't know
for me I'm not doing any voices
none at Thanksgiving because they don't
pay family doesn't know look at your
faces what'd you make them pay um but if
people come over or you go to dinner and
it's you and your wife with another
couple do they think you're going to
perform a little bit some if they don't
know me they think that's what it's
going to be like and I think sometimes
their work like they'll be worried about
that that it's gonna be is this going to
be a show oh but then they're more
worried that I'm that boring because my
in in real life we you know when we talk
off the off camera and off I'm a lot
more cynical I'm a lie I would say
edgier backstabbing you backstab is a
huge one it's tremendously large I will
stab you in the back turn you around and
stab you again um yeah it's it but
that's not me on stage so that's a
difficult that's something I want to get
to but right now there's just too much
you know with the the ESPN with the
corporate with all that kind of stuff
it's how I make money and it's I don't
want to ruin it any of little kids so
I'm careful about that as my kids are
starting to get you know to get more
worldly I think I'll let more go cuz
it's not about people like you don't
swear in your act you don't do this I'm
like yeah I just because I have I work
for people I worry about that yeah what
about now you said the behind-the-scenes
with Trump when you first yeah that was
great that was uh that was amazing I
don't know what he's like now and I'm
not speaking to any political side at
all see there I'm hedging everything
I think enhanced off off-camera so
you're healing I've got a sign in my
lung so he we're doing this guess we're
in the middle of the sketch something
goes wrong and it breaks camera stops or
something like that he's like he I'm
like okay here we go and he's like wait
a second check out something is just
pretty good does everybody think this is
good the seems funny to me doesn't seem
funny to you and all around the room yes
mr. Trump fantastic mr. Trump great mr.
Trump is like way way way way does
anybody ever say something isn't good
and he goes no and that's part of the
problem Frank I can't get real answers
so he was in on the joke and that like
made me like him a lot more at the time
I was like oh my gosh he gets it I
thought this pretty cool then afterwards
because he's telling me that's great you
know what she do is fantastic it really
is he used every adjective he could um
so he brings he goes do you have a
couple minutes I make sure he takes me
down in an elevator the elevator stops
in between floors there's a guy with
like white gloves man you know the
manning the elevator I'm thinking this
is The Sopranos
I feel like journeys gonna start playing
the elevator that was it you're done
okay so we get out of the elevator and
he goes he takes me over the kiosk and
we're in Trump Tower it takes me to the
ground floor Kia to kiosk and goes do
you like ties I'm like sure he starts
giving me all these Trump ties and he
goes do you what do you like cuff links
I'm like I don't know he goes do you
wear cuff links I'm like not yet but I'm
gonna start if you're handing them out
so he gives me a pair of cufflinks
then he goes are you married I was like
yeah he goes do you like your wife which
was a very telling question right coming
from somebody because I had the hair I'm
over here that you can choose right so
he then gives me this watch and when he
gives me the watch he takes the price
tag off of the watch and hands it to me
diamond studded watch and I'm kind of I
don't know what to think it's Donald
Trump right but it's also the ground
floor of Trump Tower so I'm not sure if
it's real or it's not it's probably not
real but he sends me out into New York
City with this diamond studded watch and
I find out that it's costume jewelry but
I'm like he's got the joke's on me Yeah
right he did he got he got me and like
that's brilliant you just played me
completely and I couldn't tell because
you're Donald Trump and it was so funny
as we're coming down an escalator
he's like do you see that Starbucks
right there that's the number one
Starbucks in the entire country and that
Howard Schultz called me the CEO
Starbucks and told me that's the number
one and you think on the ground floor a
trump tower that make sense but on the
second floor that's incredible that's
the number one and you have to go up
this escalator the number one escalator
and I said that then I goes that is
everything number one with universe
break if it wasn't I wouldn't have any
part of it can you do Hillary I can't I
don't have a Hillary you don't do as you
do women voices no I said it because it
always comes out weird I did a real seal
Donnell years ago but that was kind of
me just throwing a wig on at the time it
was because Trump was doing you know his
back and forth but Hillary has a thing
where she just kind of yells anyways I
mean you could find the essence of it
yeah Oprah is the same way we got a new
car you know you find something that can
work and with if Hillary's in it I am
back and there are no more rules it's
gonna be great y'all over to play
something okay you could have Trump or
you can have Bill Clinton right
depending on who wins yeah I mean
there's something there you want Trump
though well my way or my wife goes
around telling people to vote for Trump
or it's taking food out of it she really
does do that am i can use let's not take
because people get mad about this kind
of stuff but uh but yeah she's she's uh
she she has no shame and we'll just tell
people it's about our children and I'm
like I thought is that really true we're
doing all right who are you working on
right now well you know I've been
there's always people I want to do a
leak or so because I would love to go on
College GameDay and just do something
ridiculous that cuz he doesn't make
sense at all even when he's trying to
make sense just to watch Herbstreit
and those guys try and figure out how to
bring it back they don't know what they
what do we do here I think he just said
the F word and so that that would be a
lot of fun
uh you know everybody wants me to do a
dick bite al but there's so many dick
Vitale's I always think when there's so
many people doing but the stuff that
works at ESPN is really about ESPN I'm
for some reason I'm the guy that is
allowed to make I mean I guess uh
Van Pelt's allowed to make fun of the
ESPN a little he does it he does it's
more subtly than a late-night
yeah but management's in bed
right and that was that's what we used
to do sorta people people when I first
start like you better be careful you
know that a lot of that does I go that's
why they hired me is to be this guy you
guys are considered journalists anybody
off-limits no no there's nobody and they
usually check with the person though
that's the totally different way of
going about that Fox at Fox they just
let go do whatever you want make fun of
everybody at ESPN they're they'll go and
check and nobody said no I mean Kenny
main is another one I've been working on
just because I think it would be just so
fun to go do something that doesn't make
sense I'm Kenny main and this makes no
sense at all I'm standing here with an
awkward lean you know just to do that
kind of because the the guys who are the
history of ESPN that's those guys have
been around so long they have those fun
things we did this fantasy draft thing
and I was on with Kenny trying to do I
was standing on a box to be half his
height and just doing that you know
using my cerebral cortex we'll find out
what comes after this he's just got that
anytime and he makes you uncomfortable
awesome and it's awesome because every
wherever he goes the energy becomes his
energy you could be the most powerful
over-the-top comedic force by the end
you're talking like this trying to
figure out when we're going to break
sounds good to me
we'll be back in like what how do you do
that how do you have that much silence
and that much non-sequitur that works
I'm in awe every time I hear it so how
was the ride over by the way Oh
tremendous yeah trim everything good I
learned a lot you did different cultures
really yeah I don't know what I could
say oh you I'm scared
are you yeah a little scared you just
there was issues uh I wouldn't call them
issues just character study you like
when you look at a place and go we
should bomb that oh my goodness so that
so the driver said that I don't know is
that what is that what you're hearing um
maybe can should we save this story for
the next time Frank soon yeah because I
need him to get out of here safely yeah
I'd rather then I'd rather because I
don't know where you're going now I
don't even know I feel like you to get
write it down I feel like it's straight
because I was laughing at some of the
stuff and it was horrible
terrible stuff yeah Seaton what next
time around I think we save it this one
holds the story hold yeah this is you
came in a little shaken yes you did when
I said how you doing ah good I don't
worry about business I always worry
about business with people because I
think I don't care I don't really get
offended you could say whatever you want
to me but I think about other people in
that same ride that may not have the
same to me it's a story and it's a great
story that's going to be told next time
but it's it's a great it's just a great
thing and I want to figure out how I can
even work it into my okay but I need you
to get back to where you're going do you
need escorted out I know you're come
okay with that that that's okay so it's
escorted in the cars maybe what you need
I don't know what I'm gonna proceed can
we get do you have another car yeah
we've got him taken okay I need Frank to
get back to wherever he was yeah it was
it was a like I said I don't it's a
story for another day I want the person
to remain anonymous I don't want them to
know what I live yeah when they say yeah
I've been to jail a few times I think
we're making a left turn here it's like
when they do it's like when they'll talk
about a product in baseball halfway
through you know a bouncing ball down
the third-base line
tune in you know what it was one of
those kind of did he know about this
show your driver no yeah that was the
joke when I walked in yeah yeah I said
he goes where you go like Dan Patrick
show Dan F and who the guy who's
probably paying you to drive you here
yes [ __ ] yeah probably know he's a Frank
Caliendo
you can see him on Long Island and
Atlantic City this weekend you can find
out all of his pit stops here on Frank
on stage Don can I throw a couple other
because Oklahoma City's coming up I know
there's the Iowa run Seattle and in
California to Las Vegas big one too yes
so the Orleans Hotel Frank on stage calm
is everything always great to see you
yeah let's see if I make it back
yeah to tell that story again yeah I
would love that
the Dan Patrick show week
on audience